>> I'm going to do a quick
review of function syntax and
some of the other things
we've seen with functions.
We know that a basic function
starts with the func keyword and
then a function name.
And then, anything we want in the body
of the function goes in between
the curly braces here.
Some other formats you may see
are like this one that takes one
integer parameter.
And you can see its type Int,
indicated here.
And this last example we see
takes multiple parameters.
We have one integer parameter and
then a second integer parameter.
And as we've mentioned, and
you've probably noticed,
you've been using functions
since the maze app.
Here are two examples
of the print function.
And you'll notice here on the right side
we can see what is being printed out.
Or you can click these bubbles to
blow it out into the middle of
the playground.
Next, let's see an example of
defining our own function say hello.
This function takes no parameters and
it prints out hello.
Nothing too complex here.
Let's take this one step forward and
look at a function
that takes a parameter.
If we scroll down a little bit we'll see
this is the function sayHelloToStudent.
And all this boilerplate code up here at
the top is to create a Student struct
and initialize some
Student struct instances.
And then, in the body of the function
we've taken the student parameter and
we're printing out it's name.
And since it's called multiple times,
if we click
this little white circle here to blow
it out we see the very last printout.
But if you click value
history we can see all
three of the printouts because
of these function calls here.
In this next example,
we have the same student struct,
and we have a new function
called greet student.
It takes multiple parameters.
It takes one student parameter and
then a boolean parameter called late for
class.
To call this function,
we write the function name,
greetStudent, followed by our student
struct instance, in this case gabrielle.
And then, we need the external
parameter name, which for
this boolean value is late for class.
And then, a boolean value,
in this case false.
And here we see the output
of the three function calls.
Let's move on to naming parameters.
I really want to focus on this section.
The code here at the top
is the same as before.
We define a student struct, and then we
create some student struct instances.
But the function definition is where
things really get interesting.
For the student parameter we
specified both an external name and
an internal name.
And then the lateForClass, by default,
uses this same internal and
external name lateForClass.
So, we can see here at the bottom for
all three of these function calls
we're using the external names for
both parameters.
And remember, by default the very
first parameter normally doesn't use
an external parameter name unless
you explicitly specify one.
Now, I want to show you something that
took me a really long time to understand
when I was looking at
Apple's documentation.
And you're going to be
doing this more and more.
We haven't started to
talk about classes yet.
Classes can have functions known as
methods that are associated with them.
This is the UIViewController Class.
And let's pick one of its methods.
I'm going to search for
viewWILLDisappear.
If we click viewWILLDisappear it'll blow
out all the extra information about this
particular method.
So, we can look at its swift
definition here at the top.
Notice how the function takes
one parameter, animated.
And for
an external name it uses an underscore.
When you see this on Apple's
documentation it means that default
external parameter name should be used.
And remember, since this is the first
parameter, the default external name for
it is nothing.
It just is omitted because
its the first parameter.
And notice, the viewWillDisappear does
not use any external parameter name, and
that's the default behavior for
the first parameter.
And that's it.